in 1982 Jim Henson proved he was more
than just the Muppet guy with an epic
fantasy about the struggle for power and
survival in a fantastical land decades
later the story is continuing with a
Netflix miniseries so there's no better
time to delve into the untold truths of
the Dark Crystal perhaps the least
popular sketch in Saturday Night Live
history is the season one recurring bit
the land of Gorch
it featured fantastical and grotesque
monster creations with names like spread
and ploobis although it stemmed from the
minds of Jim Henson and company it
lacked that signature Muppet magic after
one year all parties involved decided it
would be best to end the land of Gorch
while Gorch wound up a bizarre footnote
in SNL lore it directly inspired one of
Henson's most triumphant works in the
70s Henson developed a deep appreciation
for the work of fantasy illustrator
Brian Froud an English artist with an
affinity for bringing exquisitely
detailed fantasy beings to the page
around the time that Henson got into
frowns work Froude was thinking about
turning his creatures into a puppet
based film so he happily accepted a 1977
invite from Henson to visit his workshop
in England once roud saw the highly
detailed land of Gorch puppets
he knew Henson was the man to bring his
illustrations to life and the two
creators agreed to make a fantasy film
together the Dark Crystal is one of the
first live-action narrative films with
no visible humans in the cast it's also
one of the few in which characters speak
languages invented by linguists
specifically for the project children's
fantasy author Alan garner provided some
helpful suggestions for the Dark Crystal
team based on some ancient languages for
example a language created for the
Skeksis was based on an offshoot of
ancient Egyptian the one spoken by the
pod people is a take on serbo-croatian
spoken in parts of the former Yugoslavia
producer Gary Kurtz has noted that
people who are fluent in Polish Russian
and other Eastern European languages say
that they can recognize some of the
words for the sake of realism the Dark
Crystal filmmakers opted not to create a
new language whole cloth from scratch as
Kurtz explained to Starlog magazine
certainly it's much easier to make up
nonsense sounds but you can sense if it
doesn't have any basis in reality in a
real language there are certain
repeatable phrases and a structure which
makes the sounds mean something the Dark
Crystal held its first test screening in
Washington DC in March 1982 Jim Henson
figured the plot would be clear enough
through the characters actions and tone
but the test audience didn't think so
and neither did executives overseeing
the project they thought they had an
expensive flop on their hands and that
they'd spent 25 million dollars on a
baffling impenetrable experimental film
Henson had no choice but to follow the
directives of the people in charge and
dub the movie into English screenwriter
David Odell had to essentially compose a
whole new script with dialogue that not
only told the story but matched up to
the puppets mouth movements then Henson
had to hire a whole new cast of voice
actors then have editors sync their
words with the finished visuals in total
it took four months to make the dark
crystals audio track workable and
creating a vast and elaborate fantasy
world on par with Westeros or
middle-earth Jim Henson and his
collaborators developed a wealth of
background stories and other ideas for
the Dark Crystal there have been many
video games comics and books continuing
the story of the gelfling z' and the
Skeksis but a follow-up film never
materialized in 2006 the Jim Henson
Company announced the beginning of
production on power of the Dark Crystal
a sequel set centuries after the first
film it was to follow a girl made of
fire who teams up with a rogue gelfling
to swipe a shard of the crystal to
reignite a dying Sun producer Lisa
Henson told MTV that it was based on the
sequel idea discussed two decades
earlier by Jim Henson
Dark Crystal screenwriter David Odell
Samurai Jack creator genndy tartakovsky
signed on to direct the sequel which
would have combined computer-generated
animation with live-action animatronics
but alas it wasn't meant to be
in 2012 tart offski told indieWIRE we
did visual designs we did a script we
started testing things we were always a
couple of dollars short and it just kind
of fell apart in August 20 1960 viewed
one of the most hotly anticipated and
long-awaited projects in recent memory
the Dark Crystal Age of resistance a
prequel miniseries to the Dark Crystal
it all started to come together around
2011 when Clash of the Titans director
Louis Leterrier took some meetings with
the Henson Company he had watched the
Dark Crystal on the Titan set constantly
for inspiration prompting the company to
ask him to helm its Dark Crystal sequel
project he was excited about what
happened before the events of the film
prompting the company to change course
and make a prequel miniseries instead of
a sequel film filmmaking technology has
significantly progressed in the past few
decades
solet Rea had many more tools at his
disposal when making age of resistance
than Jim Henson did back in 1982 but
Letarte EA is such a super fan of the
original film that he vowed to use
practical effects as much as possible
the canvas is much bigger but the
feeling is the same while some CGI
technology was implemented it was only
to digitally remove puppeteers from
footage of action-heavy scenes but
there's still a lot that can be
accomplished with puppetry an age of
resistance is just one indicator of the
dark crystals long legacy and now the
prophecy is fulfilled check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the belt so you
don't miss a single one
you
[Music]